even for the sitcom side they were
looking for compelling stories your
story
very compelling we dove all into that
first interview but has anybody
approached you
about wanting to turn that into a sitcom
or anything yeah but that's not what i
wanna do i don't wanna
put out another prison sitcom or
anything about
anything about that what i'm gonna do is
gonna be responsible
and that's not
responsible you know the orange's new
black and odds and
all around they they can have all that
that's not they can they can live in
those fictitious
prison stories i'm you know lockup is
doing a good job of
telling that story so
is that what people approach to about
it's like okay we have a vision ali
you're in prison is that what they said
that's what they don't that's what they
gonna approach me about it
if if they that's the work they've seen
you do they haven't
you know they think they that's what you
gonna say alone
but i don't have a gimmick for them so
that's the thing i'm writing
about what i want to so and
that's the thing when it's not my goal
it's no pressure on me
that's other people want me to write
sitcom that's what other people think
success is that's not what i think
success is
because i'm a stand-up i didn't go to
juilliard to be an actor i didn't go to
writing school
i um honed my skills and my craft
being a stand-up i'm not a talk show
host
i'm not a um
gimmick writer i'm not a dancer i'm not
a rapper i'm not
i am a comic and i'm cool with that
maybe maybe that's a a old way of
thinking
but i know people who uh i don't know a
lot of doctors who trying to
do any other thing other than being a
doctor yeah
i don't know any lawyers who you know
trying to be something
else i think you know it's certain
crafts that people have to be
what they are if you need butchers
i don't want my butcher you know
want to be an actor and then i can't
give somebody gotta actually want to be
a butcher
so i'm just a stand-up that's it so what
are your goals with stand-up then what
you mean what my goals are well you said
the tv stuff it wasn't your goal i've
accomplished every goal in stand-up
really
but what what more's for me what is
there for me to do other than
keep doing specials yeah it's specials
because how many people
how many people get specials in in a
comedy career
very rare i mean more getting them on
netflix
i guess netflix is starting to pump them
out but netflix is not comedy central
that's the regardless of what people try
to
oh you go to netflix yeah if you go to
netflix when you're trying to
get to fight you can record your own
netflix special and sell it to him
how about that but conversation you
can't do that
i'd rather somebody put the money into
me to shoot my thing to know this is the
home
that is in the title comedy central the
central location
for comedy next hbo then i'll do a show
time
then we'll get around to doing a
netflix's that's important
to me at that time but other than that
i'm just keep pumping out specials
because i don't think nobody ever asks
richard pryor when he was doing albums
or red fox when they're doing albums
um what you want to do next
do what i want to do
they do whatever they want to do and i
want the people who hell bent on
letting people understand that you won't
have to do
you don't have to be nothing else to be
considered a successful comic that's a
bunch of [ __ ] to me
i don't want to be i have to become an
actor or something else to be considered
a successful comic what type of [ __ ] is
that
so i guess football players got to do
something else
to go to the hall of fame in football
so you got to do something else what you
got to do yeah
to get the basketball hall of fame what
do you got to do you have to play
something else other than basketball you
got to play cricket
too what you got to do so in comedy
why do i have to become an actor or
be in a movie or internet [ __ ] to be
considered a good stand-up
i guess just bringing a new awareness to
you get new new fans
if you're more if you're in more than
one place that's the more
people can find you but what does that
have to do with stand up though
it can lead to bigger venues more
more so why do you have to do i do you
understand what i'm saying why do you
have to do something else
to be considered a good stand-up well if
you're just a stand-up they can only see
you where they
stand you just stand up that's what you
[ __ ] do you are a stand-up
uh i love stand up but i'm asking
why does a stand-up comic have to do
something else other than be a stand-up
comic to be
famous for being a stand-up comic
it's just the more awareness the more
you do the more people can see you why
people not aware
but you're not doing stand-up when
they're getting away you acting you're
saying somebody else's words it's not
[ __ ] stand up
but people say they'll start a podcast
what the [ __ ] what people's they got to
do
what the truth is i mean other comics
will
do tv shows or other podcasts to then
drive new fans to
then see them do stand up
you know how [ __ ] stupid that sounds
[Music]
i mean i just do stand up i'm not on a
tv show or anything else
but i'm just thinking of what are the
most avenues that i can attract new fans
to then come see my stand-up and see me
live so instead of me
maybe doing a one-night or somewhere i
can then sell out a weekend
at a club or sell out at a theater
it though all the vehicle is to drive
stand up
but there's multiple ways to do it
beyond just stand up
i guarantee you you're doing a sitcom
your [ __ ] stand ups up
i [ __ ] guarantee it
i've seen that too i've seen it a
thousand times
yeah i've seen that too yeah
the people who was good at stand up try
to do other [ __ ] and then they [ __ ]
stand up sucks so then you're being
you're taken away from what you're
supposed to be in order to do some other
[ __ ] to get other fans to come see you
[ __ ] suck at what you're supposed to
be
yeah just like people the internet the
internet [ __ ]
are not good at stand up live that's why
they don't [ __ ] show they stand up
that's why it doesn't make sense to me
to try to bait followers but not [ __ ]
work your pen and work your craft
it's two [ __ ] different things you
doing sketches
and [ __ ] take cut action this [ __ ]
ain't nothing like me doing a live show
you it's no comparison
it's no comparison
yeah you're scaring me a little bit but
i'm just saying
the understanding is so [ __ ] up that
comics have been brain [ __ ]
to think that you have to do other [ __ ]
and your stand-up is not important when
that's what you're supposed to be
and let every and let that drive
everything just richard pride standard
was so strong that his first
[ __ ] movie was about his stand
up his life
jojo dancer that was his first movie
first movie
whoa i did not know that wow
that's impressive that's how good his
[ __ ] stand-up was
yeah and i think people have lost sight
of his stand-up was so superior that the
rest of the [ __ ] came he never abandoned
his stand-up
people trying to oh i'ma try to get here
to go there to then come back no it
don't [ __ ] work like that